I mean that there are quite a few other
forecasters have said this year IMF
playing a bit of catch up here is it
um yeah I mean it's it's a big change
from their previous forecast but to be
honest with you and you know you I
remember we had exactly this
conversation about the reliability of of
any forecast right now to be honest with
you but in particular IMF forecasts the
last time they made a forecast about the
UK which was to say that Britain was
going to face the weakest economic
growth in the G7 this year that was
widely reported uh at the time it was
what the IMF was saying and it was quite
a big four you know it was a big call to
say the UK was going to have a recession
and then most other countries around the
Europe and indeed the rest of the
industrialized World we're going to do a
lot better but now it's pretty much a
reversal of that they are saying that
the UK is not going to face a recession
this year uh it's going to be 0.4 growth
not very strong growth but nonetheless a
lot better than the minus 0.3 I think it
was minus 0.5 previously they upgraded a
little bit and now they've upgraded
created it even more and also there will
be other potentially economies within
the G7 which will do worse than the UK
this here you were just talking about
Germany it looks like German growth is
forecast by the IMF to be kind of close
to zero so the UK at 0.4 as I say not
nothing to write home about but
nonetheless a lot better than we
previously saw it's actually no longer
the worst performance in the G7 in 2023
so that will be seen as a big victory
for Jeremy Hunt or well I mean a minor
Victory but nonetheless a victory
compared with where they uh were before
the big picture though the UK pretty
much kind of if not flatlining them very
weak growth for the next few years still
very high inflation in fact they've
pushed up their forecasts for inflation
they say the bank of England may have to
do or they're recommending the bank of
England should do more interest rate
hikes you can see Andrew Bailey they're
just there is being quizzed by the
treasury select committee right now and
inflation's still a big pressure in the
UK but really it's that big headline
number that I imagine most Focus will be
on so much noise uh I think it was
towards the start of this year when the
IMF said the UK was going to fare the
worst in the G7 well that is no longer
the case they say the UK it's not
necessarily going to go be going
gangbusters this year but at 0.4 growth
no recession and no longer the weakest
growth in uh all of the G7